wrapping paper usually comes spooled if
you are curious about that process just
email me after so we're starting with
just a simple box you can just glide the
scissor right along and then in pro tip
we got double-sided tape here boom a
blanket how the heck am I gonna wrap a
blanket it's like wrapping a a sheet a
bedsheet you know what's this it's a
piece of cardboard stick it right here
you flip gives it a little form makes it
a lot easier to wrap huh looks like a
loaf of bread that's on a cutting board
but it's very small and I'm not sure if
you can see that what this person is
gonna do with this I don't know there's
no magnet on it you know what that's up
to them it's not my problem
really so you just give that a good
tough stick that right there or up here
I guess stick it on your head if you're
gonna wrap food treat it like it's
anything else so you're just gonna we'll
pull the paper over it is a card and on
the card it says the gift of friendship
[Music]
okay well to me oh yeah these are real
I'm just gonna as you can tell I really
love Christmas and so I'm happy to
finally be in a Christmas movie called
Krampus that comes out December 4th so
pack up the family and go see a scary
horror movie at Christmastime and I
think I made this present you know at
least 70% more beautiful
[Music]